it's story time come on grab your  friends and hear a tale about grandma  Lanza I mean check it these guys are  ferocious well not him  that's gizmo he's all kinds of adorbs  but I don't do cutesy gizmo has a  hardcore side I love me that red bandana  yeah but he's a total stickler for the  three gremlin rules rule number one no  bright lights to keep gremlins out of  water and three not supposed to feed him  after midnight but you know what they  say about rules eat the cookie eat the  cookie eat the cookie freedom and trams  Morpho they turn into these freaky green  beasts and wait till you meet their  leader yeah stripes a mohawk master of  mischief a troublemaker after my own  thousand-year-old heart unlike gizmo  here whoa you sing MOG why don't we jam  aram  no one likes cool after midnight  bye-bye